[Music]
So he told that everything is fine, there are
policemen present here around
12:30, this incident happened between 12 and 12:30,
some
gurus came to him, brother, take the Darshan book,
they came and  They attacked my brother and
martyred him
[music] They
also bit him with knives etc. This was just out of
enmity towards the mosque, there was nothing else but
this enmity that
everything should not happen here
[music]
[praise]
[Music]
They should remove the enmity of the genes from them.
What should they have animosity towards in the light of what they were about to reduce?
Yes, this is just that, there should not be a mosque, yes, the
police are present since day one, that is why the police come to
stop, so that
Now I don't know whether there is any wrongdoing there,
maybe if the police had tried to stop [
music] then [
music] [
music] could have happened.